JORGE CUETO: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Talks
at Google, and it's
great to have Sandy Jen,
co-founder and CTO of Honor
here with us today.
Sandy founded Honor in
2014, and prior to that,
she was co-founder
and CEO of Meebo,
which is a customer
internet company that
focused on connecting publishers
and consumers socially.
And she led their
engineering team
and then joined
Google, actually,
in the social team when
Meebo was acquired in 2012.
And before that, she also got
her BS from Stanford University
in computer science.
So it's great to have
you with us today, Sandy.
SANDY JEN: Great to be here.
JORGE CUETO: I'd
like to get started
by having you tell us about
what Honor is in your own words.
SANDY JEN: Sure.
So Honor-- our
mission, basically,
is to change the way
that our parents age.
I think aging is a
topic that a lot of us
don't talk about with people,
especially our own parents.
There's a bit of
sort of child fear
when talking about
issues like that.
And so Honor's goal, really,
is to remake the way that folks
can age at home specifically.
So we really focus on
non-medical home care,
which means that we help
folks with what we call ADLs--
so Activities of Daily Living--
things that you and I take
for granted--
brushing your teeth, getting out
of bed, going to the bathroom.
And we have a whole host
of really awesome care
professionals that
go and do that work.
JORGE CUETO: And what
inspired you and your team
to start Honor?
SANDY JEN: Good question.
So three of the four founders
are multi-time entrepreneurs,
and so we all kind of cut
our teeth on social media.
I've obviously been at
Google for a little bit.
And once we sold those companies
and took a little time off
and we really wanted
to do another venture,
we really wanted to
think about, OK, well,
what would make us really
want to work hard--
like really, really hard?
Because startups
are a lot of work.
And we ended up thinking
about what's important to us,
and we were a little bit older
a little bit more mature.
Some of us were having
kids, and we really
wanted to have impact.
That was the biggest thing.
And so when we were
getting together,
we thought about, OK,
what are big problems
that we could solve?
And we thought about
unemployment, poverty, labor,
childcare, health
care, elder care.
And then my
co-founder from Meebo
went home one day to
Connecticut to visit his mother.
And he likes to tell the story
that she gets speeding tickets
in Montana, which
you just don't get,
because there's
nobody monitoring
the freeways in Montana.
And she was driving
really slowly,
so he started to get a
little freaked out about,
wait a minute, why are
you driving so slowly?
And she was like, well, it's
just getting a little harder.
And so he was like, well,
I live in California,
you live on the East Coast.
When you're older,
what am I going to do?
I don't want to pluck
you away from your house.
And so that sort of
spurred the idea.
We really started to do some
research in caring for seniors,
and it's a really,
really big space.
And then we really honed
in on the non-medical home
aspect of it, because
it was very broken.
And when you find
something that's
really broken as
an entrepreneur,
you kind of get really
excited, because you're like,
what can I do to fix this?
And so we started to
explore that idea.
JORGE CUETO: How do you feel
like your experience working
on Meebo in the social space
has influenced your work here
with Honor?
SANDY JEN: So I would
say doing a prior startup
to doing Honor was
definitely a pre-req
to do this type of venture.
Honor is complicated.
Home care-- you're
touching people directly.
It's a very, very
hands-on experience.
And so in order to solve
such a big mission,
you need to know how to execute,
how to gather resources, hire--
a lot of the sort
of nuts and bolts
that I learned in
my first startup.
And so my experience
at Meebo really
taught me generally how
to form organizations,
how to run a team, how to hire.
There were a lot of mistakes
we made at Meebo, which,
as an entrepreneur selfishly
for a second venture,
I want to be able to not
make the same mistakes twice.
So it was a good opportunity to
take all the learnings that we
had gathered in our
previous experiences
and then really
consolidate all that
learning into a new venture.
And so far, it's
worked out really well.
JORGE CUETO: And how
long have you guys
been available to
consumers actually?
SANDY JEN: So we're
about three years old,
but we've been giving
care for about two.
And so the first year,
obviously, a lot of us
didn't know much
about home care.
I had some personal experiences
with my grandparents,
but really digging into the
industry-- it's been around
for a really long time.
It hasn't changed
much in 30 years,
but there are a lot of
nuances and complications
and considerations in home care
that, without really doing it,
you don't really
get exposed to it.
And so the first year for
us was a ton of learning,
and then we started to
take those learnings
and execute on them.
JORGE CUETO: Prior
to the interview,
I was just reading
on this market.
And it's actually a huge
business opportunity
in terms of how much
money people spend
on home care and
elderly care every year,
but it's something that I don't
think tech has addressed up
to this point.
Why do you think that is?
SANDY JEN: It's
interesting, because people
think technology, they think
old people, and they're like,
they just don't mix.
And the way we
thought about it is--
if you think about your
grandparents or your loved
ones who are older, they
use microwaves and toasters
and TVs and cars.
And that's all
technology, but it's not
in their face as technology.
And so you have
to sort of rethink
about how you use
tech to address needs
for that kind of audience.
And so for us, I think
there's just been that stigma
in Silicon Valley-- and
just generally in technology
as a whole--
that seniors don't do
well with technology.
I think it's a mistake
to kind of over-cater
to a senior audience by having
giant buttons and giant font
and basically treating them
as children without really
understanding the problem
you're trying to solve.
And so we definitely
don't think of ourselves
as a technology company.
Honor specifically positions
itself as a services company,
because at the end of the
day, our product is a person.
And I say this very often,
that we are a human services
company.
The person that we
send to your home
to help you do your
activities and daily living--
that's our product.
And so all the technology that
we build is in service of that.
So a lot of stuff that we build,
the end consumer never sees,
but it's completely built to
deliver the best care possible.
JORGE CUETO: What was the
hardest part of the process
as you were starting
out with this company?
SANDY JEN: I think
as technologists,
you have this sort of want
to automate everything
and make everything
really efficient.
And so you come up with
a bunch of assumptions.
And so as engineers,
we're like, OK.
We're just going to
build this thing,
we're going to build that thing.
This is the way it works.
You just go to visit,
you do this, you do that.
And then when you
actually start to do it--
we all ended up volunteering
in your homes to help out.
And you're like, wow,
that's not how it is.
And so we had to basically
learn to strip away
all of our assumptions.
And in the very
beginning, we had
folks who were running care
and delivering care and working
with our care professionals.
They were doing one thing, and
the engineers and product team
were doing another thing.
We were trying to build
things for each other,
but we weren't really in sync
as much as we should have been.
And I think that's a common
problem, because you make
assumptions, you work one way.
You make assumptions,
you work one way.
But at the end of
the day, you really
have to work together-- like
really, really together--
to understand what's going on.
And so once we figured
out that we were not
building the right
thing, that changed
the course of how we did product
development, which I think
is different than what you'd
find in a more traditional
software or technology company.
We really had to sort of
rethink how we did that.
JORGE CUETO: You
mentioned that you went
to visit some senior homes.
What else did you do in
terms of use of research
or validating the product
and getting feedback
on the product?
SANDY JEN: Yeah, so we knew we
didn't know anything, really.
And if you think about home
care, it's basically two-sided.
Actually, it's multisided.
You have the person receiving
the care-- so the care
recipient who could
be older or have
different medical conditions.
You have usually a family
member, sometimes not,
who might be the one
responsible for helping care
for the senior.
And then you have
the person who's
actually doing the care--
the care professional.
They're traditionally
called caregivers,
but we really wanted
to raise their profile.
The work they do is
really difficult,
so we actually call them
care professionals--
and then care pros for short--
to give them more of the respect
that they actually deserve.
And so we had to basically
talk to everybody.
So we plucked ourselves
out of the Bay Area,
because the Bay
Area's kind of weird.
As you all know, it's a
little bit of a bubble.
So we went to different areas,
talked to different care pros,
asking them, what is it you do?
What's hard in your life?
Why do you do this work?
A lot of folks who
at this wage level
could literally make more
flipping burgers at McDonald's,
but they choose to do this
work because they really care.
So it's like, why are
you making that decision?
What are the hardships
in your life?
Why do you work for this
agency and not that agency?
So just really being
open to understanding
how they're thinking.
And then when you start to get
the same answers over and over
again, then you
start to think, OK,
now I'm seeing a
pattern and a trend.
And that can then inform
the product that you build
and how you want to
create that interaction.
JORGE CUETO: Your
comment about the wages
that the caregivers
are earning reminded me
that I saw the CNN article
that mentioned that in 2016 you
transitioned from a contractor
model to an employee model.
Is that something
that continues today,
and why did you
choose to do that?
SANDY JEN: I think
in the beginning,
we were like, all
right, we're just
going to try the
contractor model,
because that seemed easiest.
And so we started
recruiting people.
And then it turns out that
there are certain restrictions
in a contractor model, that
you, for example, can't
train your folks very well.
There are certain
limitations on the amount
of personal interaction
you can have with them.
And so one of our core
tenants has always been,
if you could treat the care
pro better and put them
in a better place
in their lives,
they'll be able to
do their jobs better.
Because if you're
not happy at home
and you're trying
to make ends meet,
you're not going to be able
to care for people very well.
And so one of the things that
we heard over and over again
from care pros was
that they might
get a $0.25 increase
in their hourly wage
after staying with an
agency for three years.
There's no
performance-based reward.
There's no way to
know who's a good care
pro, who's a bad care pro.
And so one of the things that
we thought would be really cool
and that they were
asking for was some way
to develop your career as a care
professional-- as a caregiver.
And so the only
way you can really
do that, though, is to give
them signals as to what
they're doing
really well and what
they're doing not so well--
what they can improve on.
And then you can train.
And so one of the key
reasons we decided
to make the switch
to an employee model
is that with employees
you can actually
train and develop and
really invest in them
as people and as workers.
And so that was one
of the primary reasons
we decided to make that
change, and they're still
employees today.
JORGE CUETO: So then
you mentioned the value
to caregivers.
So if we look at
this in comparison
to traditional senior care
centers or senior care models,
what value do you add to
the other key players--
so then in this case, maybe
the seniors themselves
or also maybe the
family members who
are buying the care for
their senior family members?
SANDY JEN: Yeah, so the current
industry is very fragmented.
So if you think about--
I think nationwide,
there's something
like 40,000 or 50,000 agencies.
It's not because no one's ever
tried to make a large agency,
it's just really hard.
You have a bunch of people
on the demand side--
so all of your
seniors needing care.
Let's say your
grandmother might have
a bad hip and this
chronic medical condition,
and she's allergic
to dogs, and she
requires someone who
can lift someone out
of bed every morning.
Or my mother or grandmother
might need to speak Mandarin,
and she's allergic to cats.
And she has three
sets of stairs,
so you need somebody to be
able to lift her downstairs.
So the requirements for people
are super heterogeneous.
And then on the
supply side, care pros
are also very heterogeneous.
This person might be
able to lift 200 pounds,
but this person may not.
This person speaks
this language.
This person can only drive
five miles outside of her home,
because she has
two kids that she
needs to pick up after work.
And so there are all these
stipulations on both sides,
and so doing a match is
actually really difficult.
And so if you are a small
mom and pop agency--
which lot of these places are--
you don't have the logistical
operational technology
brain to do that,
because you're trying
to do it all in your head.
So you might have a staff
of a few people trying
to match all these things.
And so a lot of it
is also very analog,
so care pros will
literally have to take
a telephone in the
morning and say, OK,
where am I going to go?
They'll literally take
their notes per visit
on a spiral bound
notebook with a pencil,
and they'll leave
it on the desk.
And so we also
talked to folks who
run agencies-- they'll
literally drive around
to all their clients,
pick up those notebooks,
transcribe some of those
notes into their own system,
and then return all
the notebooks back.
So it's just very manual.
And so one of the
things that we hoped
to bring and have been bringing
is a more technology bent
on this for that rote work.
And so one of the
key learnings for us
was that you could try
to automate everything,
but we're not going to
send robots to do care.
That's not going to work.
And so what we can do, though,
is have computers do as much
of the rote tasks--
the matching algorithms,
the GPS tracking stuff--
and then let the humans
do the really human stuff.
And so we can get
there about 80%,
and then let the
humans do the rest.
And so one of the things
that we've been trying to do
is actually just give more
transparency into the process.
So if I live in California,
but my parents are on the East
Coast, and I have a
caregiver going every day,
I can't go and find that
spiral bound notebook
and have someone read
that to me every day.
So we have given an
app to the care pro.
We've given an
app to the family.
They can see notes right away.
They can call in any time.
Scheduling is a lot easier.
The technology we use
to then be able to track
and give you progress notes
on how the visit is going
is amazing in this industry
for a lot of folks.
And so just trying to up
the quality and transparency
of care itself has been
a huge goal for us--
and definitely the ability
to use technology to scale.
Because we have all
this technology,
we might require one human
to do this instead of 10.
And so when you
have that, you can
save a lot of that time to go
do other interesting, innovative
features to help
with care delivery.
Technology is definitely
used to scale,
to make better care,
better quality.
But at the same time,
we have to recognize
that it can't replace humans.
And so at the end of the day,
the human to human experience
is still the end product.
JORGE CUETO: You
mentioned that you provide
training for your
care pros, so what
does that training encompass?
SANDY JEN: It can vary
to basic skill sets.
Like how do you
lift and transfer
someone who's bedridden
out of bed into a chair?
How do you take someone
from their bed to a toilet?
There are things
like, OK, what is
the best way to assist someone
in this particular task?
And so we can also do things
like, oh, if this person has
Parkinson's, these are
specific tools and techniques
you can use to help
maneuver them physically.
If someone has dementia,
here are techniques
and generally accepted ways
to communicate or to elicit
feedback from those folks.
And so a lot of it is
skill-wise, but also,
how do you basically interact
with different types of people?
Because a lot of our clients--
their conditions vary
greatly, so it's not
like one bucket fits all.
JORGE CUETO: And in terms of the
composition of your audience,
are you looking at mainly
people who are soliciting care
for their family members, or
actually seniors themselves
who are asking for
services for themselves?
SANDY JEN: Yeah, it's both.
We thought in the very
beginning that we'd
have more what we
call adult children.
It's sort of a child or a
nephew or a family member
then responsible for
someone who is older.
But we also have folks who
just want care for themselves.
They recognize that they
want to stay at home.
They don't want to go to a
nursing home or facility.
And so having a little
bit of additional help
is actually really useful.
So yeah, it just really varies.
But we definitely
have more folks
who are getting
care for themselves
than we originally thought.
JORGE CUETO: So
that, again, goes
to debunk that myth that
seniors don't really
engage with technology, right?
Because they need to have
some understanding in order
to reach you in some ways.
SANDY JEN: Yeah, they
do have to find us.
But at the same time, we
don't require any technology
to use Honor.
That was a very conscious point.
So if you don't want
to touch a computer,
you don't want to use an
app, you don't have to.
Most of our customers call us.
JORGE CUETO: So then you're
also seeing how maybe you
can leverage old
technology using
new technology for the
platform, but for the interface,
relying on the older.
SANDY JEN: Yeah, and so those
trends will change as well.
So our current demographic-- a
lot of folks just want to call.
And also, you think about
if you're an adult child,
and let's say your mom falls--
which is a very common
entryway into home care--
you go from knowing
nothing about home care
to someone saying your mom
needs eight hours of care a day.
And you're like, oh my god,
what the hell is home care?
And so you need to figure
out what's going on,
and you're in a very
emotional state.
And so when you're in
a very emotional state,
you're not going to pick
up your iPhone and be like,
OK, I want care,
click click click.
You're going to want
to call somebody.
And so we have a
dedicated team of people
who answer those calls to
make sure that people can walk
people through that process.
At same time, though, if you
have gotten care for a while,
you know what home
care is, and all
you want to do is
press some buttons,
you can do that as well.
So there are different options.
And that will probably change.
One of our goals
is to make Honor
take care of us when we're old.
So obviously, when
we're older, the times
may be that no one wants
to call and everyone
wants to use an iPhone or an
Android phone or whatever.
So we can kind of see the trends
coming into the industry, which
is a nice side
effect of not working
in younger social media stuff.
Because I don't know what
the next 17-year-old wants
on her phone, but I do kind of
know what the next 50-year-old
wants.
So that's been kind of
an interesting change.
JORGE CUETO: And in
terms of scaling--
so I see this
in-home elderly care
as being something that requires
a lot of trust built over time
and something that people really
have to open themselves up
to and be comfortable with.
So how, as you're
scaling, do you
maintain that sense
of trust and comfort?
SANDY JEN: Yeah.
I think the biggest
thing you can do
is also always
frame your product
and your team in the right way.
So when I said we don't think
of ourselves as a tech company,
but we think of ourselves
as a services company,
that's the core.
That's the mission.
And so trust is huge.
I think a lot people are
like, oh, why don't you
just do childcare too?
Unlike childcare,
where there's usually
a hand-off where you're
physically present,
you give your child to
a babysitter or a nanny,
and then at the end of
the day the nanny returns
the child to you, that doesn't
always happen with senior care
because you generally don't live
with your parents at this age,
or you're across country, or
you're not in the same area.
And so the trust part--
it's kind of both
human and tech.
So on the human side, you
have to have a great care pro.
If the person coming to
your home is terrible,
obviously the trust just
goes down the toilet--
so being really good at
hiring really good care pros,
having the right kind
of vetting process,
the right kind of training
process, interview process.
The other part is
just supplementing
that with technology.
So we have GPS turned
on for our care pros
when they use the apps.
We can tell if
they're there, right?
That's also to
protect the care pro,
because we do have a
lot instances where
the client's like,
oh no, the care pro
never showed up, because they
didn't want to expose something
to a family member.
But they were like, well,
no, they were there.
And so it's a
dual-sided thing, where
if you just come with
tech, it's too robotic.
It's too cold.
But if you just
come with humans,
there are a lot
of non-verifiable,
anecdotal things that--
JORGE CUETO: Or inefficiencies.
SANDY JEN: Yeah, or
inefficiencies or he
said she said things.
And so you can kind of couple
those together and then
have a better package to then
improve on that trust metric.
JORGE CUETO: Also
related to scaling--
so I saw that you guys are
available in California, New
Mexico, and Texas right now.
How did you pick which
cities to go into first?
And then how do you
think about a new city
that you want to go into?
SANDY JEN: So a fear of ours is
actually just going too fast.
You hear these stories
about other companies
who have really expanded,
and they had to retract.
And we don't want to do
that, because if you retract
your service-- this
is a thing that's life
critical for a lot of people.
And so every new market
that we did currently
was an experiment.
So LA was like an
hour flight away.
Can we do that?
Texas was, OK, it's a
couple hour flight away.
Can we do that?
Different time zone, and I'm
sure all the engineers are
like, oh, time
zones, that sucks.
So we had to kind of
figure out how to do that.
And then Albuquerque
was a smaller area--
a less sort of
dense urban region.
So we're like, OK,
can we handle that?
And so we definitely
wanted to learn,
and the best way to
learn is by doing.
And so we really
carefully figured out
what markets would give
us the best learnings
to then be able to take
our model and scale out.
So yes, eventually, we'd
love to be nationwide.
In terms of the next
market we'll go to, again,
it will probably
be a combination
of are there good
partnerships, what's
the demographic look like,
services level, what can we
learn from that
particular market--
things like that.
JORGE CUETO: And
you were at Google
for about a year in 2012.
Maybe you could tell
us if there's anything
that you learned while at Google
that has helped you with Honor.
SANDY JEN: I learned I
didn't want to be at Google.
But it was really
interesting, because I
think from the
outside, Google is
this big, amazing, monolithic
technology company.
And so it was very
interesting for me personally
to learn how that worked.
When you come in, it's
like, OK, how do they
form their organizations?
How do they make a product?
How do they make decisions?
What are the roles
that they hire for?
How do they hire?
And so for me, that was
really enlightening,
because it gave me a
different perspective
on how I did my team building.
And so just being here
learning, OK, well, this team
operates this way, and
they set goals this way.
Or they hire this way, or they
structure this team this way
in order to create
these incentives to get
this goal done.
That was really useful so that
then I can incorporate that
into Honor and think about, OK,
when I'm building the team now,
how do I want to do it?
I have learnings from Meebo.
I have learnings from Google.
How can I combine
those the right way?
JORGE CUETO: And throughout
these first few years,
what do you see as something
that your team has done really
well at Honor?
SANDY JEN: We execute a lot
and crank out a lot of stuff.
I think one of the things
that we did really well
was not rush the build, and
also having the realization
that we needed to be completely
open-minded, because none of us
are from health care.
And so because the team
stayed small and nimble
and we were very focused--
I think focus for
startups is key.
Most startups die from
suicide, not homicide.
And so for us, we just had
to stay laser focused--
OK, what are we building?
And because some of us
have worked together before
and we were very
picky about hiring,
having really
high-bandwidth communication
really excels your timeline
to be able to build something.
So most home care
agencies tap out
at a certain scale, which
is why the industry is
very fragmented.
And so within three
years of our inception,
we are probably one the largest
home care entities in the Bay
Area-- maybe the largest.
It took us three years to get
there when it usually takes 15.
So it kind of speaks
to a combination
of good teamwork, the right
technology, cutting edge stuff,
and then really understanding
how to learn from things.
I think one of the
downsides of the industry
is that there are so many
well-intentioned people,
but they don't have the
means and the technology
to learn and iterate.
And so getting data is
really hard for them.
Everything is in spiral bound
notebooks and things like that.
And for us, we can
get a lot of data.
We have so much data
about how care works,
how do you do matching, what are
the trends, what are we seeing
in terms of shift lengths, and
days, and areas, and markets,
and pricing, and wages.
And so all of that you can
use to learn and improve
the service, when I think
the current industry
has a hard time accessing that.
JORGE CUETO: And as you were
deciding whether to jump back
into doing a
startup or not, what
were some factors that
you were considering?
SANDY JEN: That decision
is always very personal.
So obviously, I was at the age
where I wanted to have kids.
And so I was like,
well, it would
be really nice to
just stay at Google,
because they have really
good maternity leave
and it's really comfortable.
And I can have a very
routine schedule.
At the same time,
though, I think
I had that need to do more.
I think Meebo was great.
I mean, I had a great time.
But it didn't have the impact
that I think when we got older
we really wanted.
And a startup's
average lifespan--
I say this a lot--
is about seven years
to some sort of event or pivot.
And so I was like,
well, do I really
want to dedicate
another seven years
and have kids while I do
that and all that stuff?
And so the allure of working
with my co-founders again,
it was just really good timing
in terms of the senior space.
No one had really made
a big play in it before,
and we were like, we
can really solve this.
I use this analogy a lot, and
my co-founder does as well.
But a lot of problems
that entrepreneurs
run into that are big, if you
think about it like an onion,
is that you peel back one
layer and you're like,
oh, I could solve that.
You peel back
another layer, you're
like, I could solve that.
And then at some point,
you keep peeling,
you hit this hard core.
And you're like, crap.
I can't solve that.
There's a regulation,
or it would
take like 10 years
to build, or I
had to get government
approval, and take
would take like six
years or whatever.
But in the home care
space, we kept peeling.
We couldn't find anything
that was super hard.
We were like, oh, we could
solve that, we could solve
that, we could solve that.
And that was just
really exciting.
And so jumping back in,
we're like, all right.
Let's just do this.
Because you basically have
to commit 100% or zero.
You can't half do it.
And so we all kind
of said, all right,
let's just buckle up and do it--
have kids all along the way.
And so the decision to do it was
actually a quite easy one when
we thought about it that way.
And so far I've seen no regrets.
JORGE CUETO: Yeah, that was a
really comprehensive answer.
I think now we have
time to open it up
for the audience questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Sandy.
I have a question about--
I think what you're
doing is fantastic.
I think you have a great
product and everything you're
doing for the senior community.
A couple of years ago, I went
to the National Association
for the Deaf conference.
It was in Atlanta.
They also had one
in Phoenix as well.
And I met a lot of members
from the deaf community
who are aging--
specific groups of
seniors helping people
find a place to go.
Do you have any involvement
with the deaf community
with your product
or your services--
something that
would be accessible
for the deaf community?
SANDY JEN: So
specifically, we don't
have anything specifically
targeted towards the deaf.
But like I said
before, our audience
and the client demographic,
it's very heterogeneous.
So we have people with
all sorts of conditions.
And so we don't say,
OK, just because you
have this condition or that
condition, we can't serve you.
It's really dependent on the
kind of care the person needs.
And so let's say someone is
deaf, they have a bad hip,
they require more lifting
and transferring out of bed,
then we would just try to
find the right caregiver
to then service that person.
So we do have partnerships
with more disease-specific
organizations-- so the
National Parkinson's Foundation
and cancer organizations.
But in the future,
obviously, we'd
hope to partner
with more people.
But again, there's no
specifically targeted service
for deaf, but just
because you're deaf
doesn't mean you
can't have home care.
JORGE CUETO: Here's a
question from [INAUDIBLE]..
Besides Honor, what are key
technological improvements
that you believe have
improved elderly care?
What other technological
improvements
would you like to
see in the space
to improve the
experience for both
the caretaker and the elderly?
SANDY JEN: Yeah, I think the
biggest thing is probably
just access.
There are a lot of
devices in market,
a lot of technologies that
are, like I said, really
specifically
targeted for seniors.
But they're taking a
very non-granular stance.
So like I said, the bigger
buttons, the big fonts.
And if you talk to a
lot of older adults,
they don't like things
dumbed down for them.
They're like, I'm
perfectly capable of using
a regular device.
So I think there needs to
be a change in the attitude,
I think, more than
the actual devices.
Because if you sort of rethink
the way you frame technology,
you can--
I know plenty of seniors who
use iPhones and Android phones
in a very expert manner, and
there are some folks who don't.
And so I think if you change
the way that you target seniors,
I think that will
be a big difference.
Things that I think have been
really helpful for folks are--
more educational tools
for folks who help seniors
is probably a good step.
So the fact that we have
an app for care pros
is actually a huge, novel
thing for the industry.
But it makes them
better enabled to help
people who require help.
I would say one thing is that
a lot of the physical access
things that you and
I take for granted,
like walking upstairs,
going through a door,
remembering a lock code,
those kinds of things
could probably be improved
as the senior population gets
larger.
So basically, I think that my
biggest thing is not specifics,
but more of the
attitude change I
think is probably more important
than the actual physical things
that are being built.
JORGE CUETO: And
related to that,
have you thought about maybe
expanding your sphere of care
into providing support services
for the family members who
are maybe learning about working
or supporting their family
members who are becoming
elderly and maybe
developing additional needs
that they didn't have before?
SANDY JEN: Yeah.
So home care--
generally speaking,
people don't think about it
until they really need it.
So home care is
usually triggered
by an acute event, usually a
fall or a surgery or something
medical.
If we had the conversation
a lot earlier,
we could actually then introduce
care in a more lightweight
manner, so then that way the
transition into home care
is less jarring.
In terms of family members, we
do have a lot of family members
who get home care
for their spouses
or their parents
as respite care.
So they are the
primary caretaker.
They live with the
person receiving care.
But they might need
a day off, or they
might need three
days off every week,
because it's kind
of a full time job.
And so they supplement
with Honor or home care
to help with that.
And I think the
other part of it is
that a lot of people who are in
this situation feel very alone.
There aren't social networks
for people who are giving--
who are receiving home care
for their family members.
And no one talks about this
on Facebook or whatever.
It's not like you're saying,
oh, my mom got care today.
No one talks about it.
So opening up the
conversation, having
more community around that
is one of our goals as well.
And also, just the transparency.
It's like having the peace
of mind to get home care,
because it's scary.
It's like you're letting
a stranger into your home
and take care of your mom or dad
and doing very intimate things,
like going to the bathroom
or getting out of bed.
And so the support network,
I think, needs to be there.
Because almost everybody we
talked to has a personal story,
but they never share it,
because it just doesn't come up.
It's a very taboo subject.
So hoping to open
up that dialogue
is one of the things
that we're trying to do,
which is why I think we frame
Honor in a very positive light.
A lot of agencies or senior
related products on TV
you see are the help, I've
fallen, and I can't get up,
or it's very fear-based.
We chose amber as a very bright
color, very positive color.
We talk about it in a
very positive manner.
We have positive images,
not images that instill fear
or the more scary side of that.
JORGE CUETO: How do
you reach new clients
and convey values of trust
and safety in non-tech cities
where people have
not heard of Honor
and may rely on word of
mouth or local searches?
SANDY JEN: Yeah, so health care,
traditionally, is very local,
so word of mouth is
extremely powerful.
And you can't just win
home care market share
by advertising on
Google or Facebook,
because that's not
how you reach people.
And like I said, a lot
of times, home care
is triggered by an acute event.
And so you're not
paying attention
to anything in home care or
in the elderly space or health
care space until
something happens.
And then our job is to be
there when that happens.
So addressing the
part where someone
who's not very tech savvy
or they don't really
know much about Honor--
the one thing that we have to
portray is that we are human.
And so prior to any
home care set of visits,
we send a person, one
of our care advisors,
to your home to
do a consultation.
They talk you through the plan.
They talk you through
what your needs are.
They listen to what you need,
because a lot of times, people
just don't know.
It's like, OK, my mom fell.
What do I do?
You need someone to actually
walk you through that process.
And so basically instilling
trust via a person
is still a great way to do
it, and so that's something
that we do definitely employ.
And then also just being
a knowledge expert.
So again, when you're
emotional, and you're scared,
and you don't know
what you're doing,
you want someone to
tell you it's OK.
I've done this before.
I've seen this before.
Let me listen to you.
I can help you
through this process.
And so that's a very,
very serious thing
that we take very seriously to
make sure that when people come
into Honor and when people
think about home care,
they think about Honor as a
very calming, expert voice.
That's something we
strive to propagate.
JORGE CUETO: You mentioned
that a lot of the seniors that
solicit care for themselves
reach out to you via phone.
So how do they find you?
Do you also advertise in
traditional media as well--
Yellow Pages, all those?
SANDY JEN: Yeah.
So it's been a bit of
a challenge to find out
where those things are.
A lot of times, like I said,
word of mouth is most powerful,
so reaching the influencers
within a community--
so like a local pastor, a
local senior organization,
a discharge nurse at a
facility happens to know all
the community
members, the mayor--
whoever is sort of a
community influencer.
So that's one way to do it.
The other way is just basically
to provide care and then have
referrals.
So if someone has a
great experience with us,
they will tell their friends.
Because generally speaking,
if you were getting care,
you probably know other
people that are getting care.
And then, obviously,
you try to advertise
in the normal channels.
But those are a little
bit less effective,
just because it can be generally
not in your frame of mind
when you need to.
And then the other
part is to partner
with other people who
deal with seniors.
So we opened up
a partner network
to work with existing
home care agencies.
We work with systems-- so
hospitals and facilities,
nursing facilities, discharge
facilities-- to help spread
the word so that they know
that Honor is an option
and that we're
differentiated from the rest
of the other agencies
around, because we
have all these benefits.
JORGE CUETO: So then even
these traditional organizations
are willing to work with you?
They're not scared
that somehow you're
going to take over or encompass
some of what they're doing
and take business
away from them?
SANDY JEN: Yeah, so
it's been interesting
with that particular
partnership network.
Like I said, a lot of
current home care agencies
have a hard time growing,
because they're like,
I have two people.
It's all in my head.
I don't have technology.
It's really hard for
me to wrangle care pros
and hire care pros
and match care pros.
I get calls at 2:00 AM when
a care pro can't make it,
and I have to go and
do the care of myself.
And so they have to
deal with all that,
and they don't
tend to grow a lot.
So one of our benefits is that
we're really good at the care
pro part.
We're really good at
the recruiting part.
We have technology to
help us do all that stuff.
And so if we can take
that burn away from them,
they can actually grow.
And so it's actually a really
good partnership, where
we both benefit from that.
We both have the same mission.
We're trying to help people.
But they're good at one part,
we're good at another part.
So if you put it together,
it's actually really good.
JORGE CUETO: So I think this
is actually really cool to see,
because I think so much of the
newer service-based economy--
you look at maybe Uber
or these other startups--
people see them as supplanting
an existing industry.
And there's a lot of
pushback and conflict
between the traditional industry
and the new tech company.
Whereas here, I think
it's sort of you're
trying to work
together and make it
more of a mutual relationship.
SANDY JEN: Yeah, definitely.
Initially, people are
a little bit skeptical.
They're a little bit
like, wait, what?
You're from Silicon Valley,
what are you guys doing?
But when you explain how we
work, why we're doing this,
why we're mission
focused, things
like that, then they
start to be like, oh, wow.
If I really partner
with you, we can really
make a better difference,
a bigger difference,
and help more people.
Because a lot of these
people who come into
the industry are genuinely
there just to help people.
They could make more
money doing other things,
but they really like
the work, because they
get to interact with
clients and talk to people
and help them
through these things.
And so when they find
a willing partner
like Honor who has all these
skills and tech and teams
that they don't have, it's
actually pretty exciting.
So it's a new way to innovate
on an existing model, I think,
that both sides are
pretty excited about.
JORGE CUETO: Another
question from [INAUDIBLE]..
What are some key technology
or product decisions
that had to be made
to ensure that Honor
is friendly both to the elderly
users and also to the family
members who are on different
panes of technology
familiarity?
SANDY JEN: Yeah.
So like I said before,
we don't require anybody
to know anything
about apps or phones
or websites to use Honor.
So they could completely
do everything by phone
if they wanted to,
because we know
that's a huge part
of our audience.
At the same time,
though, we do want
to push the envelope
a little bit
and give folks the option
of using technology
to see the benefits of it.
So all the technology is
optional for the care team
of a particular care recipient.
So if the family member
chooses to use the family app,
they can.
If they don't want to,
they don't have to.
If they want to log into the
website and see all their bills
and see the care notes
and get emails, they can.
But if they don't want
to, they don't have to.
So we are trying to be
very respectful of the way
the current industry works
and how some people just
don't want to touch--
it's just too complicated
to touch tech.
At the same time,
though, if there
are folks who really
want to take that leap,
we're there with them as well.
The one thing we do require
our care pros have is the app,
and they actually love it.
So we do push the
technology on the workforce.
But it definitely makes
them more effective,
more aware of what's
going on, better
enable them to find more
jobs, find more work,
and earn more money.
So that's sort of our balance.
But yeah, if you don't
know anything about tech,
you can just use a rotary
phone and call us every day
if you wanted to.
JORGE CUETO: Elderly care
by non-family members
is common in the US, but
in some other countries
like the Ukraine, it is
not culturally accepted.
But there is a
huge market for it.
I wonder your thoughts on how to
help make a service like Honor
be acceptable in such a culture.
SANDY JEN: Yeah.
People have reached out
to us from different care
organizations from
different countries
wondering when we're going
to expand to their country.
Obviously, we'd love to do
that one day, but obviously not
right now.
Culturally, you have to respect
the way that care works.
But I think the trend of
more and more people moving
to more urban areas, more
and more people moving out
of their city that
they're born in,
tends to consolidate a lot
of the same types of concerns
around senior care.
So if you don't live in the
same place as your parents,
moving your parents
to where you are
can be rather expensive if
you live in a more urban area.
Real estate is tighter,
houses are smaller,
transportation is harder,
especially in accessibility.
So if someone has a 90-year-old
mother who can't do stairs
very well, but you live on the
sixth floor of an apartment,
that's a really difficult
thing to have to deal with.
And so even though
culturally, people
may have different expectations,
I think a lot of the trends
are moving towards
the same direction.
And so I think in
the future, we have
to just find that balance
of obviously respecting
the current tradition,
but also pushing folks
to understand the reality
of what's happening.
And then maybe
all the caregivers
in the particular country are
very different from the ones
in the US.
Maybe they're different,
maybe they're not.
If we can introduce a
way of doing things,
maybe that spurs a new
kind of trend or movement.
But at the end of the day,
I think, generally speaking,
a lot of countries are migrating
towards the same problems.
JORGE CUETO: Words matter
in the space that you're
working in right now.
How does your messaging
change between the patient
versus the family member
or caregiver to communicate
your value proposition?
What has resonated the
most and the least?
Who's usually making
the purchase decision?
SANDY JEN: So
generally speaking,
it's usually the
adult child that's
making the purchase
decision, and so it's
an interesting conversation.
So the most effective
communicator
is usually the family
member to the senior.
But sometimes it's not.
So we do have care recipients
who are resistant to care.
So they don't want
someone in their home,
they don't want care
even though they need it.
And sometimes they would rather
talk to us than their family
member, because they don't want
to expose some of their needs
to the family member.
Because what happens is
that when you expose that,
you are exposing
a lack of control,
and that's really scary.
And so a lot of times, we'll
have this interesting dynamic
where a person getting care
doesn't want to tell the family
member all that happened.
But they're willing
to tell the care pro,
because the care pro's helping.
So again, it's all
dependent on the situation.
For the most part, we do
do a lot of communication
through the family
member who is the one
responsible for the care or
the billing relationship.
But a lot of times,
when the care recipient
is the actual account
owner, then we directly
communicate with them.
JORGE CUETO: Can you
tell us about how
you train your care pros?
Is it in-person training,
or mostly online?
SANDY JEN: So most of it
right now is in person.
That's usually most
effective, because a lot
of it's physical stuff
that we're teaching.
We are hoping to expand
to more online things,
but for now, a lot of it
is physical in the office,
on the job, and also through
the app or phone or text
communication.
We talk to our
care pros a lot so
that they're in constant
communication with us
on what they need to do.
JORGE CUETO: And then
how many families
are you currently helping?
SANDY JEN: So that's not a
number we'd generally expose,
but our canned answer
to that is that we
serve the entire bay area,
LA, Dallas-Fort Worth,
and Albuquerque.
And we started in
Albuquerque, New Mexico,
so it kind of gives you a
general idea of the market
sizes.
But we don't actually
expose the actual number.
JORGE CUETO: And then related
to the idea of expanding
potentially to areas
where it's not culturally
common for non-family members
to take care of the elderly,
how do you think about not just
expanding into those areas,
but maybe creating materials to
help people in those areas who
maybe don't necessarily
interface with your business
directly, but maybe you
just provide resources?
SANDY JEN: Yeah,
so that goes back
to the point where just
being a knowledge expert
is actually really helpful.
And not just having
an online presence,
but going and getting
into the communities
is actually a really,
really positive thing.
So when you go to
a senior center,
or you go to a local event,
you can just be there and then
be a familiar face.
So then when people have
questions, they're like,
oh, you should talk
to this person.
They kind of have a better idea
of how the elderly space works.
Then you start to
embed yourself better.
And so part of the way to
get better word of mouth
is just taking
advantage of the fact
that health care and
home care is very local,
and so you have to respect that.
You can't just be like, I'm
this giant national entity.
I'm just going to go and
spread ads everywhere.
That doesn't work.
You have to really go in and
participate and talk to people
and actually be in the
community to really make a dent,
so that's generally the tack
that we'll probably take.
AUDIENCE: So what's
the pricing structure
look like in this industry, and
where does Honor place itself?
SANDY JEN: Yeah, so pricing
generally is by shift length.
So it's hourly, because the
care pros get paid hourly.
We're kind of right
smack in the middle
with most of the industry
in terms of our pricing.
Certain areas are a
little harder to serve.
So for example, if you
are a care pro making
minimum wage or a
little bit above,
a $6 bridge toll from the
East Bay to the peninsula
is a lot of money for you.
And so it's much harder for
you to get from East Bay to,
let's say, Palo Alto.
And so in certain harder to
reach areas-- so Palo Alto,
parts of San
Francisco-- prices can
be a little higher
because we have to be
able to pay the care pro more.
That's generally more of a
common trend with home care.
But generally speaking, we're
very much market prices.
And our hope is
that because we can
take a lot of the manual
work out the process,
we can maybe at some point
charge a little less,
pay a little more, and be able
to take those gains because we
have a little more
efficiency within our system.
JORGE CUETO: And since you're
using the employee model,
does that mean
that care pros have
to work a certain number
of hours or certain shifts
during the week?
SANDY JEN: No.
With W-2s, you don't have
to enforce a certain hour.
We have some folks who work
with us on more of a part time
basis, or they just pick
up shifts in the evening
or on the weekends because
they have another job.
We have other folks who use
this as their primary gig.
And so we are their
primary employer,
and they take most of
their work from us.
It's more flexible, I think,
than people think about when
thinking about employee model.
But we do realize
that care pros have
a lot of restrictions in terms
of what they can and can't do.
Folks at Google
generally don't have--
when you have trouble with
your car, it's like, oh,
it's really annoying.
But when your car
is the only thing
that is really providing
your work conduit,
it's a lot harder.
And so we just make sure
that we're respectful of that
and we provide enough
options of types
of work for our care pros.
JORGE CUETO: And wrapping
up, I have one question
about any specific
technology or product
that you're excited
about in the near future.
SANDY JEN: I would say the--
JORGE CUETO: It can
be more than one.
SANDY JEN: Yeah.
I guess just related to Honor,
there's much more attention
now to seniors.
I think that's awesome.
Before Honor, there was no
funding in the senior space.
And now we have
companies really,
really focusing on how
to cater to seniors--
not just building
devices or technology,
but really thinking about it
from an offerings perspective,
just because the baby boomers
and the senior population
is just going to explode
in the next 10 to 20 years.
So I would say maybe
nothing specific,
but anybody really investing
in not just seniors,
but demographics of audiences
that are not traditionally
invested in I think is awesome.
And that's what I'm
really excited about.
JORGE CUETO: Great.
Thank you so much, and
thank you for coming today.
SANDY JEN: Thanks for having me.
JORGE CUETO: Thank you
everyone for coming here.
[APPLAUSE]